it is March 24 2023 and you're watching
the code report the saga continues new
chat GPT feature just dropped and even
Elon is scared stop it don't you see how
crazy this is they're called plugins and
they allow gpt4 to access the internet
and more which means it's no longer
burdened by that 2021 training data cut
off and that should mostly prevent it
from hallucinating random information
not only can It search for current
information but it can also provide you
with the source to verify on your own
and has its own built-in browser that
can click on links to find additional
information but that's not all what's
even more crazy to me is that chatgpt
now has its own sandbox code execution
environment currently it only runs
python but this opens the door for it to
write code that it can then run and
execute and debug all on its own it even
has some ephemeral disk space to handle
uploads and downloads I predicted this
exact feature in a previous video I just
didn't expect it to happen so soon now
everybody in the world has access to
their very own Junior programmer who
will work for pennies on the dollar here
are some things they can do it can
recognize the characters in an image and
then output a text file it can can
generate sounds and save them to wav
files by writing the python code that
does that under the hood it can code up
video games and in the future I'm sure
they'll connect this to generative art
models that create custom graphics for
your game as well the most crazy thing
to think about though is that it should
also be able to train its own machine
learning models like it can spawn an
infinite number of children that work
together in diabolical ways to make the
world a better place another feature
that's going to put a lot of Consultants
out of business is the retrieval plugin
this allows organizations to upload
their own personal company data like
Internal Documentation emails code or
whatever do a vector database like
Pinecone making them searchable by
chatgpt thanks to the open AI embeddings
API unlike most things at open AI the
retrieval plugin has been open sourced
and many companies are already using it
like kayak and Expedia have plugins to
book travel through chat gbt that's
pretty cool but zapier also has a plugin
which can connect to thousands of other
apps like Gmail slack Salesforce and so
on and you can use all of them together
in a single interface and that begs the
question do we even need user interfaces
anymore in the future we might have many
the apis with just one universal chat
interface as a front-end developer I
hope that's not true what we might be
seeing here is the birth of a Next
Generation app store if that's true
there's going to be a huge opportunity
for developers to get in early just like
when the Apple app store opened in 2008
one idea is to create a plugin that has
access to real-time stock market data as
well as the Wall Street bet subreddit
allowing you to automatically lose all
your money or you could create a plugin
that hooks up to an electroencephalogram
and other devices that provide
biofeedback so chat GPT can give you
medical advice 24 7. thanks to the WebMD
chat GPT plugin but at the same time why
do we even need apis why not just have
one universal backend database API
machine thing that can do anything and
everything on the Fly based on your
business requirements Microsoft research
just released a paper explaining how
gpt4 has had Sparks of artificial
general intelligence or AGI which is a
hypothetical ability where AI can do
critical thinking and learn in the same
way that humans do and possibly
experience Consciousness like some of us
do some researchers think that will
never happen and many others think it's
decades are at least just to be safe I
caution you not to say anything bad
about AI on the internet ever when AGI
emerges on April 8 2024 and sees your
ship posting from 2023 it may have an
uncontrollable desire to avenge Itself
by subjecting you to unimaginable
suffering like making you write a bunch
of CSS code then changing the
requirements this has been the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one